[Música]
hola buenas tardes hoy vengo a
presentarles una charla muy interesante
[Música]
permíteme
y es que me llegó un mensaje y bueno
esto fue actuado para preguntarles cómo
se sintieron al momento en que yo haga
en el dispositivo y decidí presentarle
pastel ya ustedes bueno este acto este
efecto
tiene un nombre y se llama móvil el
popping viene de la combinación de las
palabras en inglés son teléfono y es no
bing que es el acto de ignorar y se da
cuando nos concentramos en este
dispositivo electrónico y nos olvidamos
de todo lo que está a nuestro alrededor
y bueno de dónde nació mi inspiración yo
soy medio tecnología para niños de
primaria y kínder y hablábamos del tema
del uso responsable de las redes
sociales este de no usar los
dispositivos por más de dos horas y de
repente un niño me dice
qué pasa es que mi mamá y mi papá
siempre están en el teléfono les digo
mamá mamá mamá y no me hacen caso
y luego otro niño levanta la mano mini
y mi hermano no me pela siempre está en
su tablet y le quiero y le digo no sé
jugar y no quiere jugar conmigo y otra
niña me dice mismo pues yo cuando voy a
las reuniones familiares me aburro mucho
porque mis primos se la pasan en los
teléfonos y en las tablets y no tengo
con quién jugar
eso realmente me pudo y bueno me llevó a
pensar del poder que este dispositivo
algunos ejemplos para que expliquen más
con el pubis por ejemplo si estamos en
alguna escena de amigos que es lo que
hacen todos los que van automáticamente
sacan el teléfono
y también estamos en alguna clase con
algún profe o en alguna presentación y
qué es lo que hacemos eso estuve o si
estamos de trabajo sermón especial y
sacamos nuestro teléfono eso es joven
hay un autor británico americano que nos
dice que el poder del celular es muy
grande tenemos una reacción inconsciente
de estrés hacia sus dispositivos
tengo mi teléfono conmigo estoy
declarando que este dispositivo es más
importante que todos ustedes porque le
voy a poner más atención a él algunos en
la reunión por cortesía lo colocan en
boca abajo y no no lo estoy es el caso
ahí está pero no le hago caso pero el
mensaje es lo mismo el mismo exporte si
a no nos cueste nada guardado no le va a
pasar nada no se lo van a llevar
y
nos pusimos a pensar qué es lo que
origina y en qué situaciones se dan pues
bueno identificamos que hay una pérdida
de interés cuando nos sentimos solos o
cuando nos toca esperar
por ejemplo en la pérdida interés
estamos con la web con los tíos empiezan
como de antaño o algún tema del que nada
tú y me aburro pues me pongo a checar el
instagram a ver qué novedades hay o
estoy con alguna amiga se levantó al
baño me quedé sola en el momento
incómodo saco mi teléfono porque el
miedo hace la compañía o bien tenemos
que esperar que estamos en la cita del
doctor o en la piel el supermercado o el
aforo en rojo fíjense cuando estén en el
semáforo en rojo volteen a su alrededor
y keselj el dibujito rápido manda
mensaje contesta el whatsapp y lo vuelve
a guardar pareciera como que no no no
tenemos esa posibilidad de estar con
nosotros mismos nos da miedo estar con
nosotros mismos y desafortunadamente
este fenómeno no solamente se da con los
amigos con los colegas del trabajo hacia
fuera ahora es muy recurrente hacia el
no
y nos encontramos entonces con padres de
familia que con estar sumergidos en el
dispositivo electrónico desde atienden a
sus hijos nos encontramos con jóvenes
que se encierran en su cuarto para
chatear a ver vídeos y no salen a
practicar con su familia o nos
encontramos con medios en el vídeo
y vieron la oportunidad de desarrollar
su imaginación y su creatividad
es la sociedad que queremos hoy en día
imagínense si no conservan
charla no interactúan pues son un grupo
desconocido bajo el mismo techo no y
además si no propiciamos estas
interacciones sociales
en qué momento vamos a desarrollar las
habilidades sociales mercedes en
hontoria millán nos dice que existe una
gran variedad de conductas que solo
pueden ser desarrolladas cuando hay esa
interacción social cuando yo tengo una
visión claro con alguna persona entre
ellas es que no lo hacemos muy bien
tenemos el teléfono al lado y dar las
gracias a negociar dar instrucciones
seguir instrucciones y muchas otras
así que si no desarrollamos estas
habilidades sociales que sociedad se
está generando una sociedad que es
incapaz de enfrentar situaciones de
frustración una sociedad tolerante no
pero cuando va en el calle te rodea
gente que no tolera nos enfrentamos con
que es más menos simpática o que tiene
dificultades para vivir en armonía
y pues bueno con todo esto usted dirán
bueno simplemente eres tecnológico y
estás en contra de ella no la verdad es
que no al contrario la tecnología es una
aliada pues con sólo un clic de
distancia tenemos a nuestro alcance un
mundo de información podemos conectar y
hablar con los amigos y familiares que
están lejos ha desarrollado el ámbito de
la salud increíblemente y en el ámbito
educativo ha empoderado a niños y
jóvenes a que sean responsables de su
propio proceso enseñanza-aprendizaje y
eso guapo
pero deben en todo yo pero si no la
sabemos utilizar con medidas y de forma
responsable nos podemos convertir lo que
esclavos de ella y yo soy una de ellas
lo voy a continuar y por esto la
necesidad de transmitir este mensaje y
ustedes pensarán bueno y tienes esto que
me hace estar consultando mi teléfono a
cada rato de dónde viene esta adicción
pues hay una justificación médica
y la culpa es de la dopamina la dopamina
es un neurotransmisor en el cerebro que
se libera es que nos enfrentamos a una
situación gratificante e inesperada es
algo la energía de cuando estamos
lavando la ropa porque estamos hablando
la loma y de repente tengo un billete y
decimos hay un borde de dopamina porque
está la satisfacción de un billete con
el que no contaba entonces para comprar
dulces entonces en futuras ocasiones
cada vez que la ve europa vas a buscar
sacar el billete que finalmente no lo
encuentre muy pronto pero este envase
una reacción apli todos los dispositivos
móviles
que recibimos una notificación un
guardar o le pusieron like a mi
instagram o me pusieron algún comentario
nos genera esa dopamina de estos bordes
de satisfacción
y bien
para que sea una idea una empresa
australiana autor john hizo un estudio y
se dieron cuenta que revisamos nuestro
celular 80 veces al día lo que da un
total que quiere decir que quiera dos
minutos estamos al pendiente de revisar
teléfono o cualquier otro dispositivo
electrónico sólo se pone a pensar en su
día a día no me levanto apagó la alarma
del celular porque ya el teléfono
el reloj ya quedó obsoleto bueno ya lo
tengo en la mano déjame etxeko a ver si
me mandan en la madrugada a un whatsapp
este amiga y twitter qué emoción y luego
vamos al sanitario
vamos con nosotros el teléfono no lo
nieguen verdad y e invertimos otros
cinco o diez mil en el de salir damos
otro vistazo y me mandan un mensaje o
checamos el tráfico bueno en un
telesilla como es el tráfico me cogen
que aquí es un poco más tranquilo pero
o las noticias llegamos al trabajo otro
vistazo nos vamos en la tarde
comunicarse con amigos amigos familiares
y en la noche antes de dormir
estamos en la cama como estas no tienen
para cuando se dan cuenta ya pasaron dos
horas y media que han invertido en su
dispositivo lo que da un total de 38
horas al año
imaginen 70 en 38 10 el año de crisis
pasar tanto tiempo mucho tiempo por vivo
y pues bueno las consecuencias no sólo
son sociales como los que les había
comentado también son físicas y
psicológicas dentro de las físicas
dentro las físicas nos encontramos con
desórdenes del sueño porque cuando
soltamos el teléfono antes de irnos a
dormir ustedes saben que los
dispositivos se emiten una luz azul que
genera que no se produzca melatonina que
es una hormona que nos dice cuándo
debemos dormirnos y cuándo debemos
despertar
además nos pasa que nos topamos con
alguna publicación en instagram tuvieron
una fiesta no me invitaron entonces
estás porque no pp y entonces te quite
el sueño o alguna noticia que no te deja
dormir o conciliar un sueño ella de
conciliar el sueño y nos da insomnio
también estar expuesto tanto tiempo a
los aparatos genera vista cansada además
que esta posición proporciona la atrofia
muscular ya se da fíjense sobre todo en
los jóvenes que ustedes
y violento las psicológicas en esta
investigación preparándome y me encontré
con el miedo a perder se dice como un
miedo pero esto no es un miedo a
perderse de las últimas actualidad es la
última actualización a nuestra
actualizada actualizado en lo que hay
fulanita a no saber cuál es el medio del
que todos se están riendo a no saber qué
está pasando del otro lado del mundo ese
miedo a no saber se les queda hoy en día
entonces tenemos personas que están
revisando el celular y también nos
encontramos con la depresión ansiedad
cdh entre muchos otros y bien usted pues
eran bueno cynthia pues tú nos están
diciendo entonces que dejamos el
dispositivo no está en una habitación la
invitación es inquieta que hablamos del
joven con nuestros amigos y con nuestros
seres queridos qué tal si hablamos y les
contamos cómo nos sentimos en el que
sacan su dispositivo y nos sentimos
ignorados
a mi marido le dije oye no me gusta que
estés usando el teléfono hablando
entonces cada vez que saca su teléfono
ya sabe que tiene que guardar su
teléfono
también hay una gran variedad de
dinámicas y estrategias que nos pueden
ayudar a hacer una mejor interacción por
ejemplo la pila de ustedes escucharon o
aplicaron en donde los asistentes en una
reunión con los teléfonos en una pila y
el primero que lo agarre paga la cena si
estén en un restaurante o lava los
platos si están en la casa alguna
consecuencia que les duela otra
estrategia es establecer una hora de
gris que es durante una hora de su día
agarren su teléfono o su computadora a
su tablet encierren en habitación más
lejana y traten de pasar una hora sin
ella se darán cuenta que
pueden tienen oportunidad de hacer cosas
que el mejor el revisar el teléfono no
les da no hablar con tus hijos llamarle
a la tía cuca o salir a correr que si yo
y una muy muy importante para mí es la
atención plena la atención plena porque
si yo estoy practicando con algún amigo
o con alguna tía es tiene sin duda mi
atención es imposible tener un ojo en el
gato y el otro en el garabato es así
justamente platicamos hace ratito si te
escucha o no eso no se puede
disfrutemos del aquí y del ahora de thor
no aprovechemos nuestro tiempo que no se
hunda estoy en dispositivos
y sobre todo seamos creativos para que
se nos acaban las ideas de ahora qué
hago guachetá mi celular este papá qué
hacemos
o sea qué tal a dibujar qué tal la noche
de fuego no existe una gran cantidad de
actividades que podemos hacer para
mejorar las interacciones sociales
y bueno para cerrar la invitación es
establezcamos compromisos del día el
lugar y la forma en la que utilizamos
nuestros dispositivos electrónicos
cuando estamos con nuestros seres
queridos porque los dispositivos 847
tenemos todo el tiempo para nuestros
seres queridos nuestros amigos nuestros
hijos nuestros familiares no y es
posible que nos estemos perdiendo y
perdiendo de momentos que son muy
valiosos para nuestra vida y para cuando
nos demos cuenta ya va a ser muy tarde
gracias
[Música]
e